no one should have a Twitter account
that hasn't uploaded a photo of their ID
are you with Jordan Peterson on this
that's be an interesting thing to try I
mean what's the argument against that
that whistleblowers couldn't operate
well you can still post you can
still do all that stuff it's just it has
to be traceable to you because we are
who we are when nobody's watching if you
want to know who you really are go
somewhere on your own on holiday or
whatever if you're driving along and you
throw the soda can out of the window of
the car that's who you really are no one
does that with kids in the back it's
interesting to kind of note that it's
the difference between character and
reputation reputation is what everyone
else thinks about you you know who you
are and yourself it's interesting to me
to think about the way that we act when
nobody is looking tells us an awful lot
about ourselves it's that adage about
listen to how he talks about his mother
and how he treats the serving staff at
the restaurants when you're on dates
it's like a good litmus test because
that shows when the stakes are
incredibly low how do you show up as a
person